oui jean christophe en a marre comme on
a envie de le comprendre la psychologie
des enfants est complexe et nous échappe
quelquefois alors pour mieux cerner
cette question nous avons demandé à
françoise dolto d'examiner le cas de
jean christophe pour en tirer les
conclusions plus général sur ces enfants
qui ont besoin de nous écoutons
françoise dolto et je crois que on est
un petit moment à la retrouver mais ça
ne va pas tarder je peux vous dire sans
me tromper qu'elle arrive pas heureux
mais vous savez il ya beaucoup d'enfants
dans les familles aussi qui ne sont pas
heureux lui il sait pourquoi il n'est
pas heureux se destinait pas dans son
foyer et je crois que le travail serait
de leur faire une liste d'adressés
l'enfant pourrait retrouver des gens
qu'il a aimé petit une nourrice des
camarades
une monitrice de colonies de vacances
des parrains des grands-mères je sais
pas quelque chose ils chercheraient et
puis deux ou trois parrainage n'est pas
un seul je crois que c'est ça qui est
mauvais c'est encore de subir une
personne qui veut bien s'occuper d'un
petit garçon non lui donner des adresses
de ferme qui prennent trois ou quatre
enfants dans la région y voilà voilà tel
ou tel ou tel endroit tu pourrais aller
il faut que tu leur écrivent pour leur
dire que tu voudrais y aller tel jour et
convenir ça avec eux c'est pas nous qui
veut qu allons le faire c'est possible
et c'est à toi de te mettre en acte
accordé avec dirt electronic arts ea
grillé ou à partir de 8 ans il ceci
aussi bien dans une famille que dans un
foyer qui est un substitut familiale oui
en fait il faut éviter d'en faire des
assistés
oui il faut que l'enfant puisse prendre
des initiatives et pour cela que je
faisais des initiatives dans des lieux
prévus
et s'ils ne sont pas prévues contrôler
et c'est ainsi que l'enfant apprend à
vivre que ça soit dans une famille dans
un foyer je crois que c'est la même
chose
barcella je crois que c'est intéressant
un enfant musiciens pourrait sortir chez
des gens musiciens un enfant qui aime
les musées chez quelqu'un qui a un
enfant qui aime
le bricolage mais pas du tout c'est ce
qu'on peut faire dans une famille à
l'utopie puisque ça se fait dans les
familles qui y voit un enfant tient il
est intéressé au moteur mais je vais
chercher fait chercher un mécanicien qui
voudra bien que tu y ailles les
mercredis après-midi à partir de 12 ans
c'est comme ça que les enfants de passer
leurs loisirs
un enfant qui dit à 10 ans j'en ai marre
mais ils luttent rive ils le disent tout
le temps dans la famille j'en ai meurt
puis c'est pas vrai il en a marre cinq
minutes après ils rigolent rang mais non
mais non c'est bien qu'ils puissent dire
j'en ai marre vous dit jamais j'en ai
marre même quand vous êtes heureuse ça
ne veut rien il faut qu'on peut pas être
égal toujours contents il n'y a pas de
lieu comme ça s'il n'y a pas de tension
il n'y a pas d'avenir non plus on ne
cherche pas s'en sortir
oui françoise dolto que vous retrouverez
demain dans l'émission de gérard holtz
sur france inter le téléphone bleus qui
a bien voulu s'associer à notre
initiative d'information sur le
personnage